hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to wick now this game was
recommended to me by Wade so who knows
what that means as far as the quality of
the game goes I'm sorry wait I didn't
mean that come back to LA I miss you
anytime it's got a comfortable couch
teenagers entered woods
one is blindfolded they're playing wick
play missing children haunt the woods
and can be seen by candlelight oh that's
good there's a good premise so I'm gonna
be blindfolded by my friends tossed into
the woods not as much as a goodbye and
then possessed by a demon children
hunting the woods
don't worry I'll protect you I'm serious
those kids used to play in these woods
but one by one they disappeared people
used to come up here and leave stuff in
case the kids were still alive they left
candles burning but the candles moved
inside nobody would let their kids come
up here after that don't tell me you're
buying this no I know one of the kids he
was with they were up here playing wick
too real what was that someone's out
there
game is this that's not fair at all
you guys aren't very good friends why
wouldn't you even watch over me from the
bushes teenagers leave friend blind fool
didn't lock the gate they plan to return
in 6 a.m.
personal effects collected 1 game rules
to backpack contents entered into
evidence
what entered in evidence guessing there
was a police report filed well that does
bode well for my survival chance
midnight huzzah here whoa I just got
every memory from playing slender all
over again in an instant survive the
night well that's not good oh I couldn't
just hop that there's two barbed wires
on that it might chafe my groin as I
topple over alright was this of his so
slender oh hello you to collect stay in
the light I'll do that but what happened
to this is bad
that doesn't seem to be any light to
stay in not even a moon not even a
starry night to guide my path I am alone
amongst the trees
hello you can't scare me I've played
hundreds of horror games before I've got
balls of steel the size of walnuts I
don't know if that's a compliment or not
but that's what I'm sticking to and you
cannot shatter my ball I got to get off
the ball train here there's something
ominous happening in the woods over
yonder way okay son of a [ __ ] okay
break these balls walnuts the steel ow
what did I do
ow Oh No my emotions I'm so hurt by my
friends leaving there's no line to stay
by Oh God oh I can't see Hey
alrighty then I didn't even see what
happened I can't see a goddamn thing
it's so foggy what is that is that thing
am I still running oh boy
a school bus whoa hey that's not good
question mark I didn't know this cool
books that came with car alarms all
right then I'll go on still can't see a
goddamn thing I have to let him match Oh
finally I was probably supposed to take
the candle in the beginning but I didn't
do it cuz I'm an idiot I was too
panicked and talking about my wall nut
balls for some goddamn reason that's the
theme of this game that's the name of
the episode mark pliers wall nut balls
oh man reminds me of South Park
I'm not Chuck with salty balls yeah
protect that I gotta admit the graphics
are good now that I can see them but I
couldn't see them before because it was
horrifying and something dropped in
front of me in the fog and I probably
[ __ ] myself
just to give some more personal
information that you guys did not okay
hi what are you doing back there sassy
oh hey oh you are creepy looking okay
can't run run I knew I'd make it okay so
there are dots in the woods that I did
not see before and I probably should
have saw that earlier but I wasn't
paying attention because I was talking
too much about myself and I am important
press f to transfer light I did do that
and did I pick up a bottle of booze or
something on the way over here because I
could've sworn then when I was by that
campfire something shook like a bottle
of booze
maybe the drinking will help me and my
survival here of probably not why my
friend sure our dick bags for leaving me
on this deserted island I think it was
was it what is this just some closed off
park it's not deserted island at all is
it I mean why would it even be whoa that
I oh those drugs are kicking in
apparently why am I here what happened
why am I here what happened I reared or
am I questioned a few times because I'm
still just as confused as I was in the
last sentence alrighty then I guess
teleportation is the thing that I should
expect in these woods of Hell oh look a
water tower that's awfully convenient
for a desolated environment sure it
reminds me of slender but I don't want
to make too many parallels or else's
game is gonna stab me in the button then
make me regret every choice I made in my
life see I'm not entirely sure what I'm
supposed to be doing here because I
don't know if it's about note collection
because start running for no reason
exercise is important for the lungs
keeping the weight off and strengthening
the balls you want to be strongest oh
god I can't run I can't run no more my
legs haven't done my Jazzercise I need
to go back to Pilates class help me
but help me talking about me huh behind
my back [ __ ] oh this candle up that
candle stand the light to reduce fear
well I got a lot of that mostly because
I'm out of candle I'm gonna start again
just because you know brew wind sprints
for everywhere you never know when
you're gonna need this survival
expertise of this hey look at that
don't think run yeah that's what I was
doing pretty much I never think when I
do let's play I'll just talk about my
balls a lot and then you know hope
things work out for the best okay I saw
blinky blue oh okay oh god I'm back at
the beginning aren't I
the very beginning isn't it gosh dang it
I got to reduce my fear by staying close
to this candle oh we haven't I've been
here before
Oh ding damn oh damn reading his comic
books comic books ow
boy I wish my friends would come back
for me
that would be delightful I don't know
how I'm surviving in the Schneider force
I don't know how anyone would survive in
this night oh I want dude friends I
still can't wrap my head around the fact
that people would honestly leave their
friend behind in the woods with nothing
but their balls to defend them with and
things do and do what is that what was
that
was that a geezer oh I can't run anymore
unlit early out of run maybe maybe I
shouldn't run I thought [ __ ] I wonder
if I've on oh no I only have one match
left I am
around davao hey i just spend my
resources sprinting when i should have
not been doing that these are this is
the opportunity that i should have saved
up all my wind sprint energy i'm gonna
die wait someone actually lives up there
what are they like a thousand years old
here's two bucks for a new padlock can I
go now okay archives revealed old
pioneer site in the woods homestead
burned down in 1924 family listed is
dead but children's bodies never located
field officer interviews local residents
news archive 3 and photograph power
enter near new evidence ok
oh so this is kind of like Emily wants
to play we reach each thing is a night
I'm gonna die in the next one I
guarantee you that so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
get some beers boy